hello my name is Craig baron and we are
in the lobby of the Linwood done theater
in Hollywood California
with an exhibit of some of the artifacts
props and miniatures that went into the
making of the 1956 sci-fi classic
Forbidden Planet this is a 20 inch
miniature of the C 5 7 d space cruiser
used in the filming of the special
effects for Forbidden Planet
the hyperdrive as you see below is a
light effect it allowed the crew of the
United planets cruiser
c57 D to traverse the vast distances of
space at faster than light speeds we
also have on display the prop control
panel used to control the hyperdrive
from the Flying Saucer
and as you can see it has many unique
control features like a minus infinity
indicator we also have one of the
original hand prop lasers or blasters as
it was called in the movie Forbidden
Planet and as you can see I just can't
resist picking it up and my only
disappointment is that it doesn't really
work also on display we have a
collection of concept designs that are
painted on photo enlargements from
author Lonergan's
art department at MGM Studios this
unrealized sequence would have shown the
advanced er confronting dr. Morbius
played by Walter Pidgeon at the film's
climax in the 1970s film historian Bob
burns rescued this artwork from a
storage building on the MGM backlot that
was slated for demolition the artist who
ultimately created these images is
unknown
you